bonsoir à vous jean marc à merci d'être
avec nous sur arte france alors qu est
ce qui a retenu votre attention
aujourd'hui
bonsoir samantha magic a retenu mon
attention c'est évidemment la reprise de
l'activité
ça faisait si longtemps qu'on n'avait
pas vu une réunion en présentiel comme
ça avec autant de monde dans une salle
qui était grouillante de développement
d'initiatives
on se serait cru dans une grande foire
au business parce que c'est un forum de
business est un forum d'affaires alors
le forum économique a été marquée vous
l'avez dit par un programme d' analyse
de la situation après qu vide
tout le monde est d'accord sur la
nécessité de retrouver un rythme de
développement qui permettent de
s'adapter aux changements et dieu sait
si les changements ont été fort pendant
skooiz changement par rapport à la
digitalisation généralisée à la fois des
entreprises mais aussi des
administrations et des états changement
par rapport à l'environnement c'est un
peu la première fois qu ici on a abordé
ce matin les questions de d'économie
green d'économie verte de façon à
amorcer la décarbonisation de des
systèmes de production ni psy m'a frappé
aussi et ça c'est un peu le revers de la
médaille c'est que l'ambiance ce climat
est beaucoup plus lourd que dans les
années précédentes notamment ya bien
deux ans la question des sanctions a mis
tout le monde assez mal à l'aise encore
aujourd'hui les entreprises russes sont
mal à l'aise les entreprises
occidentales et notamment les européens
les américains également qu'ils sont
elles très nombreux souffrait et 2 de
cette situation donc pourtant leur
gouvernement est à l'initiative alors
les chefs d'entreprise ont beau dire que
lee sont là pour faire du business
ils ont beau dire qu'ils sont là pour
faire des affaires signées les projets
et bien la pression politique les rentes
et les préoccupent
alors on s'en souvient en mai 2018 lors
d'une précédente édition du forum la
visite des manuels macron telle occasion
d'ailleurs de mesurer le dynamisme des
échanges franco-russes vous avez fait
allusion
jean-marc au contexte géopolitique
compliqué qu'en est il des échanges
franco-russes est ce que c'est le même
dynamisme tout de même
alors alors c'est vrai que en mai en
2018 j'étais là c'était l'heure était
plutôt à l'entendre conviviale
d'abord parce que l'ambiance économique
était bien différente un le la
croissance économique était au rendez
vous un peu partout dans le monde on
était sortie de la fameuse crise des
subprimes et on essaie d'envisager des
plans à long terme le président poutine
était venu à paris
la versailles exactement et puis il
avait invité emmanuel macron à ce forum
ici avec des projets et des projets y en
avait des investissements des projets
des changes les projets et même des
projets de collaboration monétaire on en
était à discuter de savoir si l'euro par
exemple ne pouvaient pas être utilisées
dans le paiement des factures de gaz et
de pétrole
depuis cette époque c'est vrai bien tout
a changé c'est plus difficile
le coc vide évidemment à casser la
croissance les incertitudes politiques
ont un peu hypothéqué la confiance et
les échanges commerciaux entre la russie
et l'europe entre la russie et la france
eh bien on a un peu baissé et il faut
donc que les reconstituer ils ont baissé
au profit de qui ils ont baissé
évidemment profit de la chine parce que
la russie s'est retourné vers la chine
alors il ya la question des sanctions
qui revient il ya la menace de nouvelles
sanctions
il ya des répliques russe sur lesquels
on réfléchira à propos notamment des
avoirs en dollars qui sont détenus par
le fonds souverain à moscou alors les
partenaires économiques ici sont très
prudents sont très réservés
ils essaient de calmer le jeu mais ce
que l'image ledoux hypothèque un peu les
perspectives ya deux problèmes à régler
le problème politique qui sont
importants 1
la rivalité entre la russie et les
etats-unis qui rejaillit sur les flux
commerciaux évidemment et puis une
europe qui a de plus en plus de mal
finalement à choisir sa position
entre l'amérique d'un côté la position
géographique de la russie de l'autre et
une europe qui a beaucoup de mal à
coordonner ses efforts et accorde les
sont indiqués alors malgré tout cela
jean marc ce qu'il faut s'attendre tout
de même à des annonces importantes lors
de ce forum
[Musique]
il faut s'en faut s'y attendre parce que
davantage de coopération oui parce que
la pandémie et mondiale coopération sur
les problèmes de santé coopération sur
les problèmes des échanges
d'informations coopération sur les
vaccins ya un certain nombre de contrats
qui vont sans doute rendu public
concernant la les conditions dans
lesquelles on peut continuer de signer
des contrats sur le pétrole et sur le
gaz la france d'ailleurs est en pointe
là dessus notamment avec le groupe de
total energy qui a convaincu la russie
mais qui avait pas eu de mal à le faire
parce que c'était déjà dans les dossiers
de travailler à une décarbonisation du
pétrole vendu et deux essais et du gaz
de façon à ne pas attaquer
l'environnement alors sinon on sera
toujours en risque d'incertitude sur un
certain nombre de questions alors les
accords commerciaux et sont qui marchent
sont les accords sont sont sur les les
verts sur le la technologie sur
l'innovation est aussi sur les
investissements
jean marc sylvestre en direct de saint
pétersbourg on vous laisse profiter du
beau temps
également on le voit derrière vous les
gens profitent là bas merci à vous
[Musique]